e aí galera to voltando ao todo bom
vocês vamos em directo o ano de 2014
está começando ainda está passando
rápido pra [ __ ] e olenka virada do
ano foi ontem e hoje é de 3 então eu
como torcedor ter ajudado a 6 cara eu tô
com o cara bichos como capitão boni
maria elvira que ajudar vocês até um ano
bom eu não digo bom assim mais - boston
não que na virada do ano é todo defende
o bom no mundo tá nossas vidas tudo vai
ser bom tudo vai ser apurado mundo não é
quando começa então vou passar aqui pra
você e é uma coisa que eu pensei um ano
de 2012 e seu filho onde houve treino
então escrevi comando muito massa pra
mim então vou passar pra você a primeira
coisa que eu pedi pra você fazer noite
2014 é cumprimentar margens pessoa bom
dia boa tarde boa noite quente um bom
dia ele parece uma coisa bem simples né
mas ele vai te ensinar um valor que
muitas coisa tua vida não vou te ensinar
a 8 mas não vou dar um bom dia para uma
pessoa que eu sei que não vai me
responder exatamente esse valor que o
bomdia ensina vez o caráter do bom dia
com uma pessoa que ela me respondeu
sinto que ela não vá a minha bota aquela
carga na galera o mundo o mundo inteiro
é movido por interesses tudo tudo tudo
está interessado em algum posto que a
pessoa dá hoje está interessada pois em
troca até o aniversário que a pessoa faz
é uma troca de cores você vai lá pra
comer com double-double a [ __ ] fiant e
você vai dar o que o presidente para
pessoa o interesse é tão grande que eu
vou aniversário se o presente for 50
reais eu como metade do bolo e
documentados aqui era só para não sair
pedra mundo inteiro é movido por
interesses para escutar bem o que vou
dizer agora é pra mim olha pra mim
escuta o que eu vou dizer agora será que
o seu interesse é tão grande que até um
bom dia e não vai dar professor é
esperando receber outro cara esquece o
orgulho de poder passou de boa noite e
boa tarde
obrigado senhor vai mudar tanto o ator
vitor vai ver quanta coisa poderá
acontecer de ser humano ser melhor é por
favor não seja burro cara eu já vi
vencer
tanta coisa que fico me faz querer que o
mundo tivesse acabado em 2012 eu já vi
tanta burrice
em frente que eu fico indignado eu vou
contar pra vocês a minha triste história
do dia que eu fui tirar um dinheiro pra
ir no cinema ela tarde é vantagem solar
a de teresina é como se fosse hoje eu ia
assistir sim em hollywood eu fui comprar
eu vi que estava faltando dinheiro eu
voltei lá no caixa do shopping
meio-campo de tirard banco estava cheio
e eu vi que tinha um caixa que só tinha
uma mulher tinha vários cachorros tinha
vários filhos grandes e eu vi que tinha
um caixa só com uma mulher ali porque só
quem eu vou pegar o treino fui para trás
dessa bendita senhora galera eu juro pra
você e essa senhora estava tentando
tirar a 23 reais em caixa é tudo 23
reais na turma para tentar ver quem dava
certo e repetir de novo altar a fom e
precisava tirar 10 mil estou só pra
poder completamente em cada compra um
aviãozinho pipoca 23 reais
é o tipo de coisa que a gente fala assim
pouca pedro álvares cabral que merda que
estou feia descobrir-se brasil cara para
montar cuidar para chegar a psp o animal
existe nota de três reais eu não sei se
ela realmente achava que existe uma nota
de três não só não queria que faz uma
moeda de um real e que não sai também tá
aí você não sabe por favor não tem que
tirar três reais o favor não sejam
burros você fazer alguma coisa por favor
pergunte a alguém que você não souber
pergunte a última coisa que eu pedi pra
você fazendo você ter um ano melhor
nesse ano teria que seria muito fácil
chegar aqui pra você falar assim a de
valor os amigos que vocês têm acesso nem
os seus amigos mas não é isso que eu
quero falar outra coisa o que eu quero
pedir que vocês façam 2014 é o seguinte
seja aí é isso que te amigo todo mundo
quer agora ser amigo é muito fácil
apontar para fazer a fila é falso plano
que me ajudou e eu precisei fulano fez
isso quando eu precisei todo mundo quer
ter todo mundo quer ser rodeado de gente
mais rodial mundo
é eu tenho um pouco muito grande que a
idéia de adolescente para baixo sabe eu
queria muito que vocês crescesse com
esse valor a cabeça de você que é muito
importante vocês e amigo não só tem eu
não vou falar aqui pra vocês é uma
pessoa boa pra você não matar a moça não
roubar pra você não fazer isso fazer
aquilo que isso você já sabe eu nunca te
mostrar o que tu já sabe o que tu já
sato tem que fazer por lá também vou
ficar passando a mão na cabeça agora
essa via que eu dei pra você por favor
siga elas assim não sei é se você assim
por acaso eu sei é uma coisa que o
pessoal assim uma coisa na minha cabeça
se quiser um jóia neste vídeo você me
ajuda pra [ __ ] do m3 um canal
disparou e foi com a ajuda de vocês eu
tenho uma missão aqui de transpassar o
negócio mais ajuda é de vocês
então dá um jovem e eu quero que você
comente aqui em baixo o que é que você
está esperando para o ano de 2014 ea
primeira vez a assistir o vídeo no canal
se tenha que inscreveu toda vez que
tiver bilhões mas também para o teatro
engraçado aí outra coisa é a música pcd
fases quem fez pra mim a música pensei
que fazes quem enviou pra mim foi um
cara que é muito amigo meu que é um
eagle ele também tem um canal no youtube
que esse canal aqui se você quiser
clicar aqui para se inscrever no canal
dele pra você também é receber as
atualizações dele é eu quero fazer mais
estado e alguém me mandar letra eu fazer
uma paródia e jogar aqui no canal ligado
em você quiser pode mandar no twitter
que é esse twitter aqui eu queria também
possui a justiça para que eu ficasse
aqui muito obrigado a ir falam